well the wait is almost over for black
widow
it's about time the movie got delayed
not once not twice but
three times due to the covet crisis yeah
but that did not stop scarlett johansson
from pulling off the biggest
surprise wedding of last year
you decided to get married during the
pandemic
so what how special was it for you i
think when you can
get through what we've all been through
then you come out the other side and
you're like okay
we're in the foxhole you know and we did
it you know that's really significant
scar joe and hubby colin jones tied the
knot eight months ago but
she's been the black widow for a decade
now scarlett's doing what not even
rdj has done she's executive producer of
her
own marvel movie are you officially
like the first avenger slash producer
of the bunch on their of their own
standalone film
yes come on come on you know i have to
say
that actually in many ways was my
greatest accomplishment on this film we
made the movie because we
wanted to not because we had to then you
know really got to focus on what we
thought was the most important part of
natasha's story
that's not my story this avengers origin
story hits theaters and streams on
disney plus with premier access
on july 9th it also stars florence pugh
david harbour and rachel vice james
bond's real life wife
if molina met bond in a back alley who
would come out the other side
i think they both worked with cuts and
bruises
you had quite an action moment i felt
like i was watching tom cruise sir
no man i am the opposite of tom cruise
that is a
fake plane and a fake window and a lot
of
the cgi between the two of you is
bananas
my plan was to drive us away gloria plan
sucks it feels like that y'all been like
you know sisters for a really long time
right that's what i keep on telling
carla he's like i don't want to adopt
you get out of my mouth